ce que nous avons créé ici est peut-être unique et
toute l'existence humaine nous avons créé le paradis
Ben est le père de six enfants ils
vivent au fond de la forêt les plus
jeunes ne sont même jamais sortis
de la forêt du tout habillés quand
nous plaisons la genèse de  c'était moi en tant que
père aux prises avec mes propres questions
sur le genre de parent qu'il allait être et
comment allez-vous être préparé
aux États-Unis contemporains aujourd'hui, nous avons
essayé d'élever les enfants dans un état d'
auto-examen et d'
auto-  amélioration physique mentalement de
toutes les manières vraiment
Viggo était profondément informé sur la
vie en harmonie avec l'environnement naturel que
je vivais dans le nord de l'
Idaho c'est là que j'ai fait ma préparation
juste avant de venir, cela m'a aidé à être
là deux semaines avant de m'assurer que j'en avais
envie  était réel d'allumer les feux
de la cuisine du jardinage toutes les choses
qu'ils ont faites n'étaient pas réalistes
maman doit être à l'hôpital en ce
moment au cœur de l'histoire de Captain
Fantast  c'est la femme de Ben qui décède ses
parents pensent que je suis en partie à blâmer
Leslie avait une maladie nous ne pouvons pas aller aux
funérailles de maman nous voulons te voir maman
grand-père ne peut pas nous opprimer nous quittons notre
petit coin de paradis au milieu
de forêt pour aller à ses funérailles et lors de
ce voyage sur la route, notre mode de vie entre
en conflit avec la société soi-disant civilisée
tout le monde est malade qu'est-ce que
tu veux dire tout le monde est si gros que comme les
hippopotames le film devient vraiment un
voyage de découverte c'est un  réveil en quelque
sorte le choc culturel entre ma
famille sœur vous savez que leurs enfants sont
très différents Michaels
Oh local ou biologique comment avez-vous tué
ces poulets avec une hache juste la nuit j'ai
osé servir notre poulet historique alors vous l'
achetez dessus il est déjà mort c'est en quelque
sorte  un échauffement pour ce qui vient plus tard, c'est-à-
dire quand nous arrivons aux grands-parents qui
m'ont presque frappé si je voulais te frapper je
t'aurais frappé Viggo n'est pas un héros
et je ne suis pas un méchant
nous sommes tous les deux des hommes compliqués  essayer de
s'entraîner  nos différences dans la façon d'élever
les enfants même s'ils survivent
à tout ce que vous leur
faites, ils ne seront absolument pas préparés
pour le monde réel et je pense que
le contraire est vrai en vivant de cette manière très
extrême qui  n'est certainement pas
courant dans notre culture,
ce qu'il fait est fou ou
incroyablement génial Je vais vivre ici mais
Nana grand-père ce n'est pas possible
allez chercher vos affaires allons-y allons-y
je te déteste c'est vraiment un film sur le
conflit  de cela, dans quelle partie du monde
vivez-vous et dans quelle mesure cela fera
-t-
il de l'écart, il s'agit de la parentalité et des choix que nous
faisons en tant que parents, en particulier la paternité
les six enfants et mes enfants seulement à quel point
ils sont talentueux en tant qu'acteur, c'est à quel point
ils ont été difficiles  travaillé pour préparer et nous avons
abordé tous les jours du tournage
ensemble en tant que famille,
ce film me donne l'impression que ce serait
vraiment un film spécial et cela fait
pour beaucoup d'entre vous des
moments de réflexion humoristiques  ts
j'espère sincèrement que vous n'avez pas été condamné
et je pense que vous avez été votre fille
m'a appris beaucoup de choses tout à l'heure serez-
vous ma femme la première fois que j'ai lu le
script je me souviens d'avoir ri autant que j'ai
pleuré en le lisant et j'espère  c'est
ce que sera la réaction du public
lorsqu'il verra le film fini